simple
the thing about simple
the pgl
the son of a [ __ ] did it
[Music]
this past weekend the pgl stockholm
major came to a close and for the first
time in two years a new cast of cs go
major champions
was crowned we had fateful whiffs easy
diamond coins zywoo used my op
yes you heard me we'll get to that
and as you've all been reminding slash
harassing me to say on steam twitter and
in the comments sections of some of our
videos
sasha simple costillia the greatest cs
go competitor to ever live
can finally call himself
a major winner all right so before we
dive into the one don't at me i have
been waiting
years to do i must ask that you
beautiful cs stands like the video
subscribe to the channel and calmly
place your crosshair over that
notifications button and click
is it too soon to make a nico joke okay
i'm not even really gonna like sum this
one up because i shouldn't have to i
mean just
look at your timeline if you are even
remotely interested in esports you know
that this past sunday natus vincere and
their sublimely talented star fragger
simple were crowned champions in the
first cs go major we've had in two years
there's no time he just has to watch
that clock dig down this is it
i'm taking the major
and let me tell you if you were gonna
win one major
just one
this was the one with a two million
dollar prize pool and a peak of almost
2.75 million concurrent viewers almost
three times as many as the last major
it's safe to say that pgl stockholm was
something of a super major i'm not gonna
make any lull dead game jokes since it's
kind of cringe and honestly no one
should take that stuff seriously to
begin with but i will say that it is a
very nice validation of the fact that
not only is counter-strike healthier
than ever literally but that the esport
has seriously grown in the last two
years so how big of a deal is this for
navi
well
pretty big i've given this history
lesson before on don't at me but for
those who don't know
na'vi were essentially the last great
tyrants of the original counter-strike
in between 2010 and 2012 they won four
majors in succession and made six of the
last seven major finals that 1.6 ever
had the thing is as soon as they came to
cs go they proved
incapable of winning a major zeus who
led the 1.6 roster won a major with
[ __ ] gambit but never navi so for the
ukrainian superpower to finally achieve
cs go glory
is genuinely a massive dub especially
when you consider how dominant their run
was stockholm stand up and celebrate
because you're champions
of the ptl major stockholm
21.
[Applause]
having just secured themselves a grand
slam navi literally trounced the
entirety of pgl stockholm's legends and
champion stages to become the first
undefeated major winners in cs go
history they swept nico the whole of
gambit and xaiwu without dropping a map
oh and speaking of navi's quarterfinal
bout against vitality did anyone else
recognize that op that zywa was using it
was big beautiful blue and
i kept thinking it looked eerily like
like my op thanks to my boy xavier over
at prodigy i was able to ask zaywoo if
he would do me the honor of using mai
gungnir in his quarterfinal showdown
against navi and since azai was a
[ __ ] king he happily obliged meaning
that the op that i own has killed simple
on the main stage of a major that smoke
will delay them
zai wu patrolling
and it's a first on to simple no less
does that mean that i have almost killed
simple on the main stage of a major
no
but it's a pretty stiff flex speaking of
csgo's colloquially accepted goat
now's the part you've all been waiting
for the part where i dimitri
simp
over simple
meet back here after simple wins
meet back here after simple wins well
guess what kids simple the greatest
player to ever touch cs go
can finally be called
a major winner
it feels like i told myself that i will
stay in navi
and we'll major with him i promised
myself
and we did it and
a lot of people didn't believe and make
some jokes but we [ __ ] did it and
major is ours major is navi
of course i never doubted him for a
second and have the ever illustrious
diamond coin to prove it
in fact if anyone did doubt him
you're just
you're just controlling not only did
this man add yet another mvp medal to
his collection but he finished the event
with a
1.47 rating making him the highest rated
competitor in major history the catch as
dust 2's jeffrey moore pointed out is
that both flusha and apex's ratings were
1.0 instead of 2.0 and as hltv's very
own striker chimed in to confirm a lot
of those additional stats weren't being
tracked by them so it's pretty much
impossible to say who the actual highest
rated player is they're also only taking
into account the one single major as
opposed to an aggregate but you get the
idea either way i'm going to stop
talking about this before a crowd of
brazilians starts to form and i get
heckled for refusing to unremittingly
accept that coldzera number one of
course there's other stuff to talk about
as well like
bit navi's 18 year old newest edition
and how he's just like the greatest
rookie alive this kid has played two
lands won both of them and it's netted
him a grand slam and a major title
[ __ ] tops and vibes is this just the
beginning of greatness for you
yes
and i would be very very remiss if i did
not talk about g2 putting up one hell of
a fight in the grand final
and just how outrageously unreasonably
cracked nicola kovaches
like bro that near ace clutch on nuke if
he wins that and they win the map
tell me that's not a graffiti
he's gonna be pushed to ot or can he
of course that's not the nico play that
everyone's talking about the nico play
that everyone's talking about
is the deagle whiff times it to
perfection
and simple sitting no no
an absolute disaster
that was it that was it again
that was it
mirage was one click away
oh my
now some people were saying that the
dude got cs goad but to me if you slow
it down and watch it frame by frame it
does look as if he just genuinely
misaligned the shot is it true that as
machine said in the cast mirage was one
click away
it is
overwhelmingly likely but as pimp was
apt to observe that is a very very
difficult shot to land in a major final
at match point with a crowd of 10 000
plus people roaring at every pixel your
crosshair traverses
even if you discount first shot
inaccuracy or the fact that nico wasn't
crouching facing the side of simple's
head and watching as simple himself went
from crouching to standing
it is a crazy hard shot to hit would i
have liked to see a third map
of course but even if nico didn't get cs
go and it doesn't look like he did fans
are giving him
way too much of a hard time
like for real this guy carried g2's
lifeless corpse across the finish line
plenty of times in this event
he's allowed to miss one shot anyway all
in all
[ __ ] heater of a major wouldn't you
say so just a killer killer way to not
only celebrate our love for
counter-strike but bring it back to the
world stage in a way that new fans old
fans prospective fans could all enjoy
can't wait for the next one
i feel bad
i feel bad making a negative a guy in my
stack made a nico joke last night and
literally all four of us were just like
bro
bro
like
too soon [ __ ] dude come on like please
chill like
jesus give it let it breathe a little
bit like this
sounds like an idiot
and full josh brewery on that line
good heater of a major bud anyway all in
all
f word eater of a major bud